[Music]
why is time uniform I think time is
uniform because nothing happened at the
inception of the universe there's my
picture again total uniformity of
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
rolls over into being something and in
my view inherits the uniformity from
which it stems now I'm not saying that
there's not something like a big bang
and so on I am saying that when
absolutely nothing rolls over into being
something apparently something then the
uniformity of the parent is inherited by
the child
so since absolutely unit absolutely
nothing is uniform I think that the at
the inception of space and time and in
particular of time time becomes uniform
and so you have the conservation of
energy so if you don't do anything at
the at the inception of the universe
this is where indolence comes into it
you automatically have a law which says
that energy is conserved
I suppose one of the questions that
might come to your mind is you know how
much energy is there in the universe do
we draw that uniform line there or there
or there or somewhere else how can we
measure the energy of the universe where
do we put that line because once we've
got whatever energy we've been given
we're stuck with it for all time well
you can measure the energy of the
universe what you do is you weigh a
galaxy determine its mass multiply its
mass by C squared equals MC squared so
you've got the energy that is
represented by that galaxy and then you
look at the universe and say well
there's lots of galaxies aren't there so
we do it for that one and we get a
certain energy we measure say the mass
of that galaxy add it to the first get
more do it for this one get more do it
for that one get more and you can see
that if we do it for every galaxy in the
universe we get a colossal energy where
did it all come from well scientists are
circumspect folk or should be and they
say well have I really considered all
the energy in the universe and the
answer at this stage they haven't
because when you have a gravitational
attraction between two entities in this
case two galaxies because it's an
attraction it lowers the energy so so it
lowers the energy and so what we've got
to do is to go back to our original E
and say well that galaxy attracts that
galaxy so this is reduced a bit
this galaxy attracts that galaxy add it
add it in you can see where this
argument is going currently and this is
speculation
I do not conceal this a speculation it
looks as though if you do this for the
interaction of every galaxy in the
universe with every other galaxy and you
include dark matter and you include dark
energy it looks as though that the total
energy goes down and down
deceiver so where'd you draw this line
you draw it there there is no energy in
the universe the question of asking
where all the energy came from dissolves
that's like that's what science does it
looks around and says okay you're
puzzled by big questions let's really
look at the core of this question to see
whether it really exists and my
suspicion is say there's a speculation
that there is no energy so you don't
have to account for where it all came
from for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you